while we wait for Wonder Woman's second
solo DC EU Adventure to arrive in
theaters here's a detailed rundown of
everything we know about this a tea set
sequel and a look at all the rumors that
have surfaced surrounding the project
here's our warning now potential
spoilers for Wonder Woman 1984 ahead
with Wonder Woman patty Jenkins became
the highest-grossing female director of
a live-action movie so it should come as
no surprise that she'll be the sequels
director meanwhile veteran comic book
and television writer Geoff Johns
confirmed he was working on a script
Expendables co-writer Dave Callaghan was
later reported to have been recruited to
work on the script with John's and
Jenkins in January 2018
Jenkins spoke to Entertainment Tonight
Canada about why she didn't necessarily
see Wonder Woman 1984 as a sequel we're
actually making a totally different film
it's its own movie completely it's not
Wonder Woman - to us it's an entirely
new adventure together so what are the
details of that new adventure the title
gives some of it away the story will
take place in 1984 we'll have to wait to
see how Diana's experiences in the new
world and form her in important
decisions like where she falls in the
David Lee Roth vs. Sammy Hagar debate or
if she thought David Lynch's dune
adaptation had enough guitar solos
Jenkins also told Entertainment Weekly
in June 2017 the story will take place
in the US which i think is right she's
Wonder Woman she's got to come to
America it's time as for just when the
follow-up will hits the release date for
Wonder Woman 1984 has moved around the
bits currently it's scheduled for June
5th 2020 we got our first look at gal
gadot on the set of Wonder Woman 1984
and in costume in June 2018 with the
caption she's back getup posted a shot
of herself dressed as Wonder Woman to
her Instagram account Wonder Woman's
garb in that shot doesn't seem to have
changed much from her first film it
seems a bit shinier than it did in
Wonder Woman but that's about it and
that could be the effect of lighting
rather than the clothing itself but that
wasn't quite the case by early June 2019
when director patty Jenkins revealed a
dramatic poster featuring gal gadot as
Wonder Woman in a stunning new gold
costume set against a colorful colitis
go background it's only speculation but
considering the more regal feel of the
outfit one possibility is that it points
to a possible return to Themis Kiera
Diana is after all literally a princess
and might be expected to look the part
if and when she goes back home in
December 2019 jenkins took to twitter to
counter what she called false
assumptions about the romantic aspects
of the upcoming Wonder Woman 1984
pointing to a Collider article headlined
Wonder Woman - we'll have a new love
story
Jenkins tweeted quite a few people
including this headline seem to be
completely misunderstanding or making
some pretty false assumptions based on
one of many vague quotes I made about
something I can't say anything about the
false assumptions Jenkins referred to
were rumors flying that in light of
Steve Trevor's death at the end of
Wonder Woman the hero would have a
completely new love interest the quote
from the Collider piece that sparked all
the speculation was from a broad
description of the film among other
things Jenkins said Wonder Woman 1984
would have a great love story again and
a couple new unbelievable characters who
I'm so excited about who are very
different than in the last movie
considering the quotes it's difficult to
blame people for speculating but his
fans would eventually learn it was a
little too soon to count Steve Trevor
out of the dating pool though the
dashing pilot went boom at the end of
2017 s Wonder Woman rumors swirled he'd
returned in Wonder Woman 1984 in June
2018 patty Jenkins confirmed it tweeting
welcome to Wonder Woman 1984 Steve
Trevor along with a production photo of
Chris Pine is Trevor in 80's era clothes
as a transplant from nearly a hundred
years ago
Trevor's time shift will likely be even
more jarring than it was for that other
veteran named Steve who woke up decades
after serving in a World War Trevor will
likely be very confused once he sees
some of the more extreme eighties
fashions and equally bewildered the
first time he hears Devo in late July
2018 The Hollywood Reporter broke the
news that Natasha Rothwell was joining
the cast of Wonder Woman 1984 best known
for her work as Kelly on HBO's insecure
Rothwell has joined the Wonder Woman
eighty-four production but nothing has
been revealed about her character
Rothwell responded to the report by
tweeting simply I have no words
meanwhile Rothwell fans responded to
that by flooding her with
congratulations and support one
possibility that seems likely is that
Rothwell will play an 80s answer to the
first film sidekick role of a tack Andy
who is played by Lucy Davis after all
Roth Wells work and show business has
mostly been in the realm of comedy so it
seems pretty likely that she'll provide
some comic relief in this film as well
interestingly when the DC comic book
universe went through yet another reboot
a few years ago a new version of edit
candy began appearing in the comics and
she definitely bears a resemblance to
Roth well time will tell if or how this
popular connection could pan out or if
Rothwell is playing someone else
entirely
in February 2018 that hashtag show
reported that the cheetah a super
villain known for locking horns with
Wonder Woman in the comics would be
Diana's antagonist and Wonder Woman 1984
only a few days later deadline reported
the surprising news that Saturday Night
Live alum Kristen Wiig was the top pick
to play Wonder Woman's be my nemesis our
report that was confirmed the next month
with a tweet from patty Jenkins along
with what could be a still of Wiig as
the cat lady from the production if
nothing else it probably rules out Wiig
appearing as this cat lady a cat is an
angel that poops in a box though she's
known mainly for her work in comedy Wiig
has clearly been making strides to show
her dramatic range in movies like 2017 s
mother 2015's the Martian and 2014's
welcome to me Wiig will be playing
Barbara and Minerva an ambitious
ethically questionable archaeologist she
gains her powers a new half human half
feline form when she interrupts a ritual
to an ancient African God while cheetah
is one of Wonder Woman's oldest villains
some are speculating she won't be the
only bad guy in Wonder Woman 1984 at the
end of March 2018 The Hollywood Reporter
revealed actor Pedro Pascal perhaps best
known in his role of Oberyn Martell in
HBO's Game of Thrones had been cast in
an undisclosed role for Wonder Woman
1984
in July 2018 patty Jenkins tweeted a
photo of Pascal in character Jenkins had
nothing to say about exactly who Pascal
was playing in the photo but the most
popular theory so far is that he's
playing Maxwell Lord an enigmatic
businessman who was first introduced to
the comics when he helped fund a new
eighties iteration of the Justice League
years later he would be revealed to be
much more villainous during the lead-up
to DC Comics 2005 to 2006 line wide
event Infinite Crisis Lord kills the
Blue Beetle one of the heroes who was on
the Lord's ATS Justice League team
Wonder Woman is branded an outlaw in the
Infinite Crisis prologue series the Omak
project when she kills Lord on live
television by snapping his neck in
January 2019 we got this covered cited
sources who delivered Wonder Woman 1984
story details that would solve the
mysteries of Pedro Pascal's casting as
well as how Steve Trevor could have been
resurrected according to the report
Pascal is indeed playing DC Comics
Maxwell Lord he's searching for
artifacts to grant him godlike power and
in this endeavor he enlists the aid of
archaeologist Barbara and Minerva it's
during the search for these artifacts
that Minerva is transformed into the
cheetah and she blames Lord for the
curse not yet having the power to
protect himself from someone as strong
as the cheetah Lord asked Wonder Woman
for help using one of the artifacts he
presumably finds perform an ER vez
transformation Lord resurrect Steve
Trevor in return for the Amazons
protection obviously none of these
details have been confirmed but it could
explain not only why Trevor is back but
why he apparently hasn't aged footage of
an action scene from Wonder Woman 1984
was shown in July 2018 at the San Diego
comic-con Warner Brothers film slate
panel the footage wasn't released online
but according to reports the footage was
well-received in spite of being a rough
cut
viewers reported the scene begins with
Wonder Woman crashing into a shopping
mall to stop two armed men in the middle
of the action a little girl puts herself
in danger when she walks up to the
superhero and exclaims oh my gosh
once Wonder Woman gets the little girl
to safety she takes out the gunman
leaves to the malls ground floor and run
out of the mall and on into the city one
writer at Birth movies death noted
happily how compared to 2017 s Wonder
Woman this scene was quote decidedly
brighter faster and brace herself
sillier while appearing on deadlines
crew called podcast patty Jenkins spoke
to the question of why she chose 1984
America as the time and setting for the
sequel to Wonder Woman
Jenkins didn't get too deep into it but
she said more about it than she had
previously I picked in 1984 for a very
specific reason I think it was the it's
the it was the pinnacle of the success
of the 80s in my opinion because it's
before the markets you know started to
get a little more struggling as the 80s
went on and it was like the the top of
the top you know it was such an
incredible time and you know I feel like
there's something about the excess of
exactly that period of time which is so
linked up to where we are right now in
the world while there's no way to know
for sure what Jenkins means until the
movie is released or alternatively until
she opens up more about it she seems to
be pointing to social and/or political
themes and subtexts she set the film
specifically at what she calls the
pinnacle of success right before things
got shaky er it's only speculation but
maybe she wants to warn us that we're
getting ready for a similar decline
while we still don't know for certain
exactly how Steve Trevor will be
returning to the land of the living and
Wonder Woman 1984 Chris Pine spoke with
Wonder Woman co-star Robin writes in
early June 2019 about the upcoming film
as part of varieties actors on actor
series Pine didn't get too specific but
what he said hinted at the notion that
his role in Wonder Woman 1984 won't
bring him into the action quite so much
the tables had turned on me as a man in
terms of how I interacted and played on
the screen whereby I like I loved my
lady pine told Wright that the tables
turning in this way didn't represent an
easy transition he talked about trying
to get patty Jenkins to let him in more
action scenes and joked about how the
mantra of the production for him became
not about you my eager comes out I'm
like well I want the big clients
they check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite superheroes are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]